obviously you're on the biggest show
ever that young Hollywood has obsessed
with do you feel kind of a
responsibility to your fans being a part
of young Hollywood yeah I think so I
think I mean because the show is so
iconic and you know it literally has 75
years behind it to be the first people
to humanize these characters and to put
them to life is definitely a huge
responsibility I think we all take that
really seriously we got to talk about
this last episode at Riverdale we
finally is the Josie and Archie kiss
[Music]
are we gonna see more of that is there
more where that came from
we're gonna have to see I think you know
Archie and Veronica were definitely on a
slippery slope there for a minute
with achi being away for a long time but
you know what Archie's like he loves it
he loves to get in there
[Music]
that me that there's hope for a reunion
with Veronica of course it's all this is
there's a lot of hug yeah I think so we
find out who the gargoyle king is I mean
we've had to date yeah
you'll find out by the end of the season
I can't tell you that but I know that
you're gonna find out Chad Michael
Murray joining the show which we're so
excited about what has he brought to the
table Chad's a legend
I met him for the first time when we
were shooting the musical episode he was
out around the studio looking around and
stuff like that and I think he feels
pretty welcomed I hope he does but he's
a great addition to the cos he's a great
guy he's anything about bug-head my kid
hmm I don't know give me like two words
bug kid this guy you're gonna keeping
secrets I feel like oh yeah I've been
doing this for a little bit okay the
next episode because we were on a hiatus
this week can you give me three words to
describe it this show this season okay
suspending
interesting and weird I would say weird
should be at the top now we already we
don't we get our scripts like the day
before we start shooting and then it
shocked you in every episode when I read
it I'm short
[Applause]
[Music]